i mean retail there yeah retail therapy
yes it's great get yourself something
nice every once in a while yeah if
you're going to debt if you're not
paying your bills first yeah for the
self-love yeah that's not good oh the
going out to eat all the time the people
that are like oh okay just at me just
call me out okay it's fine
we both eat out a lot yeah we do a lot
we buy the little half cans so like oh
cherry coke for dinner tonight i'm like
ooh cherry coke for lunch tomorrow and
and dinner and oh [ __ ] and for breakfast
i'm just kidding
no but like i just i started noticing
like it's not a little treat anymore
it's becoming a habit i would always
rent a car in every city that i go to on
tour and i'm like dude these people are
not a [ __ ] driver [ __ ] you oh you
can't drive and then one day in atlanta
i was like maybe it is the problem
[Music]
hello and welcome to another episode of
big moves
hey
um we have our beautiful guests here are
our stunning gorgeous sexy talented
successful woman tell them who you are
baby nikki blades yeah
i love that introduction
you also got me hi it's gina and we also
got another beautiful lady thank you
tiff tiffany
just
we're so glad you guys are here hi look
listen
so i feel like during quarantine people
did a lot of like self-reflection
self-love
and for the most part like we always
push self-love you should always you
know work on your self-love but um i
found an article or jessica found an
article um
that says
uh six self-love things that can
actually be harmful
the topic says six times self-love is
really toxic behavior in disguise
and i never really thought about that
being a thing before never work
just be in bed yeah always
self-love yeah self-love i love myself
so i wanted to like
take a deep dive into this article
because i'm curious about it too because
my self-love is [ __ ] all you guys i'm
awesome but then that's probably not a
good thing it's so toxic
um
so the first one here is
uh
it's uh toxic self-love is when it
avoids conflict
avoiding conflict is not showing
yourself self-love it's an excuse to
avoid conflict avoid being vulnerable or
disrespect other people's boundaries and
autonomy conflict is a healthy part of
any relationship and can help you grow
if you find yourself avoiding conflict
because it's quote negative vibes then
you should reflect on what conflict
brings up
and uh what that conflict brings up and
why you're avoiding it a loved one maybe
bring up a specific thing about you
because they love and want to be in your
life but if you avoid it
it's not really helping anything one
thousand per cent it's the oh my god i
just don't like how confrontational you
are with me because i'm doing something
that you don't like and i don't like
that but that's really that's really
what it is yes you have to
acknowledge when you're the problem like
and there are times that you can only
talk through
certain situations
if okay we'll use
you they use the family member right
yeah so it's like well think of your
friends and there's gonna be times where
you don't even realize that you've
disrespected somebody or you completely
didn't take them into consideration and
you hurt their feelings a relationship
whether it's a romantic one or a
personal one like friendship work or
family like they still have to be
nurtured and you have to communicate
through that because
ultimately self-love shouldn't involve
hurting someone else yeah or
invalidating invalidating and
saying i don't want to deal with the
problem that you have with me because
it's not good for me
is extremely
toxic and that's
selfish yes for sure very inconsiderate
very inconsiderate you're putting yes
that you know you should put your
feelings first but there are loved ones
were like hey like you don't want to
lose that relationship but if they bring
something up you're like nah i'm good
and just never speak to them again
that's a relationship dead and gone you
can't keep doing that i can understand
when people are negative there are some
people who always got a problem with
something who make
things 10 times worse than what they
need to be and that is a completely
different situation than what we're
talking about we're talking about you
are deciding to not acknowledge that
you're hurting someone or you're
offending them or you know because of
how it makes you feel because you don't
want to deal with the situation at hand
that's toxic
but there are times where you do got to
cut people out that they may say you're
being toxic but in reality that's you
preserving
your energy because that person only
brings something i like okay say we're
friends
and the first time that you have a
problem with me tiff we you're like
nikki i don't like this this and this
and like [ __ ]
all right i'm sorry i didn't realize
that i was doing this to you
i apologize let's move forward a month
later
nikki i got a problem with this this is
this this that you do you're like
[ __ ] really like yo
okay let me say i'm sorry again and then
you're starting to pick up a pattern
that that person is just picking fights
with you they're the negative energy
they are seeing something wrong in
everything that's when you go okay
it's a you thing not a me thing and for
my sanity and for my self-love i'm not
going to continue this toxic
relationship yeah because it's not
serving either one of us
yeah um i have a family member who
every time they do something kind of
[ __ ] up in the family i would try to
bring it up and they'd be like oh
whatever i don't really care what people
think about it or whatever whatever and
just
brush it off and it's gotten to the
point where we don't even talk to her as
much anymore because she just does not
give a [ __ ] she's like
so
non-confrontational like this isn't i
don't want to deal with it no whatever i
don't care what people think about me
but it's like dude you're pushing away
all the people that love you because we
bring it up because we love you because
we want to
you know like even help you like hey you
shouldn't do that right
i've seen that happen too um in people's
personalities or the other way around
where it's the other extreme where it's
like
oh well see i'm the bad guy i'm always
the language yeah i'm just you know what
yeah i [ __ ] up oh well like jesus like
they just won't it's like that's another
form of avoidance where they're just
fully like yeah i am this thing that
you're saying that i am but i'm still
not going to confront it or resolve it
that's another form of avoidance exactly
or like in relationships where you're so
avoided you want to keep your peace so
bad like no i'm not going to bring up
this thing i don't like and it just
keeps on like you keep on just not
bringing it up not and you're going to
build that resentment yeah and there's
no
um communication to like grow like i
don't like when you do that and then
when it goes well after that
conversation you grow as a couple but if
you keep on just like nah nah nah i
don't want to talk i don't want to talk
about it you're not you're doing
yourself a disservice right yeah you
know because you're not
showing people how you want to be
treated
so this is at the end of the day it's
not completely self-love it's kind of
self-sabotaging yeah yeah yeah
that's a good way to put it yeah
self-sabotaging to be avoidant is to
self-sabotage yeah
because it don't go away still going to
be there the next one is when it
exhibits toxic positivity oh i hate this
[ __ ] [ __ ] yes
hate them people
i hate you
oh when you're like
you're going through something like oh
my dog just died well you need to you
know that's you need to understand you
know this is a way of life this is life
is beautiful blah blah blah you give it
a good life let people feel
that negative feeling i hate forced
gratitude
i hate people telling you when you need
to be grateful yeah i think that that's
so
stupid i don't even have a better word
for that i think it's dumb i feel like
it's so self-righteous i feel the fake
positivity we a lot of the times when
you follow these accounts or these
people we know that they're having a
self-conversation this is what they're
telling themselves
realistically those people are doing
that for themselves they post it they
say it because that's what they want to
believe now that's completely fine you
can go ahead and be positive it's when
you start being in real life scenarios
where you're like well you should just
be grateful yeah
you're blessed where you're like are you
judging me now because i'm feeling a
type of way and telling me what i'm
feeling is wrong right and that now i'm
a bad person because i'm experiencing
these feelings that you probably don't
want to feel
but you're being told like no everything
is going to be it could be worse
oh i hate that sounds worse it could be
worse and it's like yeah it could be
but you know what let me yeah let me
live in this moment let me have this
five minutes however long it is that you
need because we know
sulking is not gonna solve the problem
either we know that's also toxic but
sometimes you need to just feel and be
like look your positivity is making me
angry because you're trying to make me
pretty minimizing your emotions yes it's
just invalidating everything you're
feeling but when i see those fake people
because there is a part of you faking it
until you make it which is fine and
that's how you deal with it as long as
you're not trying to force feed it down
my throat i understand your process and
i can acknowledge that this is what you
need for you yeah but they also need to
be aware that sometimes that makes
people feel worse about themselves
and it's just not solving the problem
it's avoidance again we're just avoiding
these feelings but
it's really tough and if you find
yourself being aggravated or like
agitated by those types of people you
have to take it upon yourself to remove
yourself from it because i had to mute
people that i know in real life on
social
i've had to like
not have conversations with some people
because i
we think differently that's totally fine
but
i can't i can't get behind that but
i know why you're doing it i don't want
to say like stop it all the time because
that's your coping mechanism and that's
how you're
motivating yourself but if you can't
take a step back to say like hey that's
what i'm doing it works for me if it
doesn't work for you okay then then
don't talk to me yeah there's one thing
that i hate that people say like
um if you're going through something
like yeah well you know people over in
this country don't have this people they
their people have it worse
saying
you shouldn't be upset or sad about
something because someone has it worse
is stupid because imagine if someone
said well you shouldn't be that happy
because someone else out there is
happier
you know like that's just dumb let
people feel their [ __ ] people are going
through their own things in their lives
in different parts of the world in
different situations different scenarios
people can handle certain things better
than others but saying you know well
others have it worse okay well other
people have it better too should i not
celebrate either and that that is
something that people don't know how to
celebrate anymore people don't know when
to be happy and they don't know how to
express joy because then it's like
you're always going to upset someone
yeah someone's going to be like oh
you're showing off right yeah and
we really are seeing everybody judging
each other constantly and not
acknowledging yourself you're just like
well i was told and then that's really
what it was i was told that people in
other places have it worse than me so i
need to be grateful so since i have to
since i have to do something that i
don't really believe in i'm going to
tell you the exact same thing because if
i have to [ __ ] fake it
then i'm going to be like no no i got
told that people have it worse than me
and i should be grateful
of course we should be grateful we have
a lot to be grateful for but it doesn't
always work that way and when we judge
others for figuring out their process
it doesn't help them do you feel like
this issue here has gotten worse with
social media
that's what kind of what i noticed too
like the more
at least for me personally like the more
that i i
put myself out there
obviously the more that i'm welcoming to
come back to me and then that just kind
of makes me be like oh i don't want
i don't want to welcome anything anymore
so then that's when like that whole
thing about like not having empathy for
others whatever like quickly judging
other people i think it comes from a
place of of quickly judging yourself
because you're you're putting yourself
out there so much and you're judging
yourself and then you're like oh well
this is the game that we're all playing
right yeah we're all playing this game
yeah with social media i think of it as
high school i think of it as a place
where you have a whole bunch of people
that have different ideas but we're all
seeing that if you act one way you get
treated one way if you act a different
way you get treated another way um
without social media we had things like
high school college church workplace
where you're actually interacting with
other humans social there's a smaller
bubble too yeah but with social media
what it does is that you have so many
eyes and so many people who do not know
you at all judging you constantly and of
course it's going to be worse but it
would be like somebody
in high school going like i don't fit in
why don't i fit in because everybody
else is acting this way and i act
differently i feel judged or bullied
because everybody else like but i'm
forced in this space right you're forced
to be
at school with social we're
subjecting ourselves to it
and that's what makes it even
more difficult because we don't actually
have to use it but we are using it so
people feel
like they're forced in order to keep up
with
just life yeah exactly so
you know there's a social status on
social media that's like being popular
in high school
it's like you have to do things that you
normally wouldn't really do for yourself
because this is what's going to get me
where i need to be and then you feel
judged but the also
the flip side of why social media
is still like high school is that you
can find your community
um but it's a learning curve right like
everybody is just trying to figure it
out but it's just like we're all back in
high school and we're all watching the
cool kids or we're watching the
self-assured independent one who doesn't
need it it's like i go to class i get my
[ __ ] done i go home i got a cool life i
don't got to share with you and we're
just kind of figuring out our place in
high school again you know
so for a long time i had a habit of
snacking when i was bored but i didn't
know i was snacking when i was bored i
actually was snacking when i was bored
when i was stressed when i had anxiety
when i was sad i actually i guess i was
just any emotion i had because i
probably snacked when i was happy too i
would uh reach for food and i actually
didn't really know i was doing this
which is why i really appreciate noom
for pointing that out to me so nume is a
program that is a little bit different
than your average weight loss program it
uses psychology to help you understand
the whys behind your eating habits and
not just what you're eating but why
you're eating it so you can break
unhealthy cycles for good and make more
intentional choices and you'll also have
plenty of support to achieve and
maintain long-lasting results for me
it's it's definitely like a food when
i'm bored but also social situations
whenever i go to a party i just always
had to have like a snack or a drink in
my hand and so i was drinking too much
um when i was specifically when i was
out because i just didn't want to not
have something in my hand
and i didn't really know that that was
part of the uh the psychology behind why
i kept drinking too much when i went out
um because i definitely wasn't having a
crazy blast every time i drank too much
it was it was mostly for the social uh
reasons and a noon pointed that out it
also knew it gives you these different
exercises that you can do within 10
minutes a day you don't have to do
anything crazy drastic to keep up with a
healthy lifestyle i was beforehand uh
exercising too much which my
nutritionist pointed out was causing
stress which was blocking my digestive
system but with numes different exercise
programs all i needed was 10 minutes a
day and it actually worked much better
for me
so break the cycle with motivation and
support from new weights
psychology-based approach sign up for
your trial today at noom.com big mood
that's n-o-o-m-dot-com
big mood to sign up for your trial today
whether it's a warm cup of coffee
basking in warm sunlight or listening to
a sexy story pleasure is all around us
with dipsy your sanctuary is waiting
escape into a world where pleasure is
your only priority dipsy is an app full
of hundreds of short sexy audio stories
designed by women for women they bring
scenarios to life with immersive
soundscapes and characters no matter who
you're into or what turns you on find
stories about that intriguing co-worker
with a british accent or hooking up with
your hot yoga instructor they even have
stories designed specifically for your
zodiac sign new content is released
every week so in between listening to
your favorite stories again and again
you can always find something new to
explore dipsy also has sleep stories
wellness sessions and now they also
offer written stories it's your go-to
place to spice up your me time explore
your fantasies or heat things up with a
partner for our listeners dipsy is
offering an extended 30-day free trial
when you go to dipsystories.com
mood that's 30 days of full access for
free when you go to d-i-p-s-e-a
stories dot com slash mood
dipsystories.com
mood uh the next one is when it is an
excuse for unhealthy behaviors for
example tweak or taking a 20-minute
break from work is your form of
self-love that makes you feel
replenished but taken to extreme for
three hours that's toxic or
substances like food and alcohol and
treats is a way of taking care of
yourself but over indulging causes more
harm than good yeah we know that yeah
that's an obvious one we know we know
yeah having that little glass of wine
because that's that's fine like you
needed it to relax but if you're like i
had a hard day at work i drank a bottle
i wonder have i ever done anything like
that i am toxic i know i i know at work
there are times where i've had to learn
how to deal with my stress and to find
that balance of what is going to
help heal me versus now i'm just leaning
into it even more i'm using the excuse i
had a stressful day at work i'm gonna
[ __ ] sleep all day yeah why because i
just can't deal yeah did i feel better
yeah but now do i kind of feel guilt
like now am i looking at myself like i
really could have done other things i
wish i wouldn't have done that but i
tried to justify it in that moment
but
when you've kind of you get this achy
feeling
the you get this icky feeling to where
you're like i now am seeing that i'm not
this isn't helping yeah but look that
nap that 20 minute nap sometimes you
just okay
today was rough i tell myself this i had
a hard day at work i had a like a really
tough year i'll just be real
real upfront i was struggling with this
job and
it could have led me down such a bad
path because when you feel like you
don't have an escape you start trying to
do things
like internally to make yourself feel
better and you're trying to find out
what does make me feel better and when i
would get super stressed out i just
wasn't i wasn't in the gym the way i
needed to i stopped taking care of
myself my health um
just all the things that i feel like
made me me i started neglecting because
i was starting to now sulk in these
feelings from from work and being like
well i had a hard day at work i'm gonna
i just like don't want to talk to
anybody and then having to reflect back
and be like [ __ ] i am being really
toxic it's not it's not necessarily for
other people but it's like i'm not doing
myself any good but it took time to see
what worked and what didn't so
throughout my toxic behavior i learned
what should stay and what shouldn't i
don't drink the way i used to i remember
wanting to just get like i wanted to
forget the day sometimes but then when i
woke up hungover and i still had to go
back to work and i'm like okay that was
counterproductive yeah and you start
seeing that hey
maybe that glass isn't going to make me
feel the way that i want it to feel
this feeling is super tempting
it is like a band-aid over a bullet
wound and
you gotta tap back into what actually
makes you happy and what can be
productive and what can assist with
dealing with stress
the gym and finding a balance because
going to the gym and being in the gym
for like five hours can be
counterproductive too
it's not healthy yeah it's all about
balance
trial and error imbalance or oh there's
one shopping there's so many people like
i gotta get something to just self-love
make myself feel good yeah it goes over
people go into debt i mean retail there
yeah retail therapy yes it's great get
yourself something nice every once in a
while yeah if you're going to debt if
you're not paying your bills first yeah
for the self-love yeah that's not good
oh the going out to eat all the time the
people that are like oh okay you're just
at me just call me out it's okay it's
fine
we both eat out a lot yeah
a lot but i also know how to say like
nah i'm good i'll stay at home yeah the
fomo
fomo is a big one you're just oh yeah
yeah you think that everybody else is
living this great life so i gotta go out
and i gotta do it with the joneses yeah
you know more recently after like being
in postpartum i started
i started drinking more soda because i'm
like okay cool i don't have baby in me
anymore even though like he's still
consuming what i'm consuming through
breast milk but
like i started like indulging myself
like every night like we buy the little
half cans so like oh cherry coke for
dinner tonight i'm like oh cherry coke
for lunch tomorrow and and dinner and oh
[ __ ] and for breakfast i'm just kidding
no but like i just i started noticing
like oh man every meal
i want a cherry coke or like a dr pepper
or whatever sodas we have in the house
and i started realizing like oh no like
this is not um like it's not a little
treat anymore it's becoming a habit yeah
you need to stop yeah
so even like soda or just
yeah
fast food a lot of the
like
vices devices
all of those things we know that
everything is in moderation
and no matter what no matter how time
how many times we say that sometimes we
get carried away because it did make you
feel good it was a little tree and then
it wasn't and then it's like okay
now i see it i identify the problem then
you gotta adjust from there because then
i'll justify it too where i'm like i was
so good for nine plus months yeah
because it was before i even got
pregnant like i cut out coffee alcohol
all that stuff
and then like now that he's born i still
haven't drink alcohol because that one
i'm really like i don't
whatever i'm not drinking alcohol yeah
because i'm breastfeeding um and then so
i'm just like well you know like
we can get taco bell because i need the
calories i'm breastfeeding yeah like i
need extra calories yeah i can get them
there so yeah like yeah it's just
casey's always like come on man i'm
trying to get on a diet every every once
in a while we we understand but it's the
all the time you think it's the overkill
yeah it's the
oh yeah i've been good or oh i'm gonna
go in the gym and i'm gonna i'm taking
care of myself and i'm doing this but
now in reality you did like five classes
and now you're exhausted and now your
immune system is low and you're right
yeah you're like but i'm doing something
good for myself and it actually causes
more harm than good ooh balance is so
hard to find it is that's all about
balance but most of us
don't got it nope that's why i can't
ride a bicycle all right
um the next toxic one is when it doesn't
allow room for growth if self-love tells
you not to change yourself it isn't
self-love self-love can be a toxic
behavior if it encourages encourages you
to disconnect emotionally or always put
a positive spin on situations that
require a bit of healthy shame
the experience of reflecting on
situations for self-growth and
re-evaluation of your core values is
healthy
um it can also cause or this toxic
self-love can also create unrealistic
goals and expectations that can create
toxic shame
that is the oh
they're just like that like oh yeah
that's so and so that's just them or
like i'm always a [ __ ] that's just my
personality
[ __ ] you or the example here is the
examples of toxic positive statements
include put yourself first no matter
what or love yourself no matter what
yeah which is look i get it you know i
know why people push that but you have
to have humility and some self-shame
where you're like
yeah i love myself no matter what but
you know you said that you don't check
yourself you got to check yourself and
there is always room for improvement and
if you use this like nope i'm great i'm
gonna do [ __ ] yeah that's terrible
most individuals that are toxic coming
from someone who i
for sure have some toxic traits i
definitely know
my
[ __ ] that i need to change i don't think
i've ever had a moment where i was like
i am the best version of myself i do not
care because i'm way too self-aware but
i have seen people and been around
individuals that are like i'm good no
yeah this you
oh you're upset at how i treated you
that's how you received it so you
receiving my attitude as attitude is
just more about you than it does me
and those people
eventually
get humbled and it's never the way that
they ever think it would happen it's
never it's always like okay
cool
you you'll learn yeah yeah and
i've witnessed that you know you see
somebody that's like that's just me yeah
that's just me then
that's that's just how i am uh i hate
the whole like if you can't handle me at
my worst you don't deserve me at my best
like dude you shouldn't be giving people
the worst of your words like that like
have some humility you know but some
people don't know that like they don't
they don't know humility and they're
very those are people who
probably just stay self-absorbed they
stay toxic they there are tons of adults
that we all know i mean we're grown
right but then there are the adult
adults like you are in your 50s you're
in your 60s you are [ __ ] grown still
doing the same toxic [ __ ] like you
never grew up you never became
self-aware you're gonna end up old and
alone by yourself
you know it's wild too like about like
these people that you're talking about
because i i've witnessed this exact
behavior and we all got some family
members that we're talking about right
now yeah and then but these people are
the same people that i think that
therapy
like would never be for them right
you're just like what therapy for what
like yeah i already know everything like
i'm already giving myself therapy
i'm just like what's going on it's also
because therapy before was known as no
only crazy people go there
shame yeah it's shame the stigma behind
it but no the thing is like if you can
go to a doctor to get a checkup on your
body you should be able to understand
that you have to get a checkup on your
mind you know like
everything your emotions everything
you're going through there's no shame in
this this is really healthy upkeep yeah
i use the family as an example because i
feel like so many people can relate to
that we've seen the adults that you're
like grandma
you still want you still want to think
that way that's why nobody calls you and
i hate to say it like that but we have
so many family members that for our own
sanity that we cannot speak to that
we've had to come to the conclusion that
they're never going to change because
they think that they're right yeah and
for
us to keep
wow just to be able to like live our
lives we have to cut ties with those
people that's the
doing what's best for you because that
person is no no longer
willing right to help in your life and
they become a burden and it does suck
when you see people and you can love
them and you can love somebody from a
distance but
when you're that person and you start
being like well i have no friends or
nobody loves me or nobody cares about me
it's really because it's like you
you forced people out you refused to
show them what was your role in all of
this right and those people
most of the time never acknowledge
that they're the problem
and that's why it's toxic self-love
because in their minds everyone else is
the problem yeah everyone else wasn't
patient with them everyone else
took it the wrong way
that's why i say all the time it's like
if you notice that you're losing like
you're constantly losing friends
especially if you lose a whole group of
friends or you've seen that yeah yeah
and you're still like well no it's
because this person did that this person
that and every excuse for every person
you lost or every group you lost like
well this person did that's like well
maybe you need to understand that you
are the common denominator here yeah so
take a look at yourself and see if okay
maybe it was my fault yeah
like the smallest example i can make is
when i used to tour um with the drift
team i would always rent a car in every
city that i go to on tour and i'm like
dude these people are not a [ __ ]
driver [ __ ] you oh you can't drive and
then one day in atlanta i was like maybe
it is
oh [ __ ] that makes sense because i'm
this [ __ ] from la driving like i'm in
l.a yeah you know yeah so it takes like
self-reflection look at yourself you are
the common denominator you're the one
who's angry at every single car you're
in every city
every city i had to i'm
what i'm so thankful for the people i
have in my life right now i'm so
genuinely thankful because there was a
point in time that i didn't deserve for
these people to still stay in my life i
remember when i was the problem when i
was in these
toxic ass relationships and i'm like
crying to my friends all the time and
they're like girl you know what the
problem is or you know family and
they're just like okay we're gonna let
you figure it out on your own and then
you you realize like oh [ __ ] wow i
see what you guys are dealing with and
i'm happy that i was able to be around
people that knew how to tell me about
myself in the right way and that's
another thing too and just
telling someone about themselves and not
learning how to speak their language can
be extremely offensive and do way more
damage than good because you come off
self-righteous versus just genuinely
wanting to help someone but i know that
if i didn't apologize or make the effort
with some of the relationships i have i
wouldn't have these people in my life
and i've had to acknowledge a lot of my
toxic traits like
i know
uh that if there was a point in time to
where i wouldn't talk to people i just
want to pick up my phone i was really
going through whatever and i needed that
but everyone knew well nicki might not
pick up the phone yeah there was a day i
fell down my stairs and
something told me like yeah hey if you
keep going on this path that you're on
you're gonna die in this place alone and
no one's gonna come looking for you
because you were the one that made
everybody think that you didn't want to
talk to them yeah that was your fault so
when you need help and no one's gonna
pick up the phone it's because you
weren't picking up the phone and i was
like that was such a hard
drive and this [ __ ] had to fall down
the stairs
down the stairs
literally but i realized that yo if i
don't make the effort to change then no
one's going to care like no one's gonna
why would why would they care so that
was my hard dry pill to swallow with no
back it was really tough but it made me
evaluate life in the way that i was
behaving and also being like okay cool
it made me look at like what other
people were going yeah that's healthy
but then to not do that that's a toxic
trick that they're talking about yeah
yeah
circling back on the toxic
positivity thing i actually got taught a
lesson about that uh
late last year
because i was always about like you know
what even though i'm going through [ __ ]
i can still help people the positive
life everything look in the position
look for the positive so um i told this
story before where i was at an airport
and i was like i was going through a
deep depression period and i was like no
positive positive i'm gonna help
whatever i ended up helping this person
that i saw crying at the airport
and i was like are you okay he seemed
lost whatever and then in my way or like
in the process of helping him i missed
my flight oh and my luggage was already
on the way and it turns out this person
was just drunk oh no yeah
and then i that's when it like it really
hit me i'm like you cannot like this
toxic positivity you can't do that all
the time you know like
sometimes you do have to put yourself
first but not all the time like it's it
is a balance of balance yeah
when you know more you can do more what
if you could use science to discover
more about your body you can find out
what you need for your healthier
tomorrow with everly well everly well is
a digital healthcare designed for you
all at an affordable and transparent
price
with over 30 at home lab tests you'll be
able to choose the test that makes the
most sense for you to get the answers
you need like the women's health test or
food sensitivity test which is actually
a test that i recently took it was
really interesting to find out that out
of all the foods that were tested
bananas were somehow the highest like
rated it was actually cow's milk like
the highest sensitivity apparently that
i have and the second thing was bananas
which really surprised me like i would
have never guessed bananas and it's
actually kind of cool because they tell
you you know after you get the answers
that you're looking for now it's
recommended to me to do an elimination
diet
and see if i actually have any reactions
to banana because i've never
actually taken notice so i really
thought it was so interesting to find
out what foods i was sensitive to with
the food sensitivity test and i loved it
so much i actually purchased the indoor
and outdoor allergy test because i'm
like wait what if i'm allergic to more
things that i had no idea about beverly
well also has high quality vitamins and
supplements to support your overall
health you can choose from a variety of
options including vitamin d3 and omega-3
fish oil which ps i'm actually also
taking the vitamin b12 that they have um
super high quality ingredients highly
recommend here's how it works every well
ships products straight to you with
everything needed in one package to take
your at-home lab test simply collect
your sample and use the included prepaid
shipping label to mail your test back to
a certified lab your physician reviewed
results gets sent to your phone or your
device in just days yeah my results
actually came in in two days after they
received it which i thought it was
really fast where i'm like oh cool i
honestly thought it was gonna take a lot
longer but it was just a couple days and
you can share the results with your
primary care physician to help guide
next steps if you ordered vitamins and
supplements you can start adding them to
your daily routine right away it's so
simple over 1 million people have
trusted every well to support their
health and wellness goals and you should
too and for the listeners of the show
everly well is offering a special
discount of twenty percent off and at
home lab test at everlywell.com
big mood that's
everlywell.com big mood for 20 off your
next at-home lab test everlywell.com
big mood okay the next one says um it's
also toxic when it is selfish self-love
is about accepting one's imperfections
while also striving to evolve in healthy
ways those who really love themselves
strive for respectful balance and
harmony across all relationships so if
your self-love disregards others
feelings it's or is dishonest or is
narcissistic then it isn't true love uh
the key red flag of toxic love is the
strong narcissistic element that
permeates this type of behavior um toxic
self-love almost always creates some
sort of penalty or cost for others
whether through boundary violations uh
negative communication patterns or
disrespectful behaviors also toxic
self-love can be spotted by comparing it
to true self-love which is guided by
respect empathy and consideration for
others i'm just gonna throw this out
there most of these things that are on
this list i have one thousand percent
participating oh yeah one thousand
percent and as i was listening to that i
was like i wonder
if
someone listening to us is like these
self-righteous [ __ ] trying to tell
me what self-love is but i'm listening
to them like i am still learning how to
love myself at our age yeah all these
younger kids like oh you you know when
you grow older no no you're still
learning all the time i see people in
the 40s 50s 60s still learning about
self-love it's really difficult because
again we were taught most of our lives
not to be selfish and we sacrifice
ourselves and that's supposed to be some
especially as women yeah and you're
supposed to get some badge of honor for
not doing that but then you also get
shamed for putting yourself first and
then it's like whoa but if you neglect
yourself or say you're not going to the
gym and you let yourself go then it's
like
you're not doing this but you're like
but i'm putting my family and my time
look at what i'm doing it's
so
difficult like what one person would
consider selfish is what someone else
considers like just normal
and everybody's self-love is going to
look different but that's also when you
hear like to what extent does it become
toxic to when
and to who because right we all can be
sitting in this room right now and i
could be like yeah if you don't want to
pick up the phone because you're going
through something right now that's what
you needed to do that's fine you say
that to somebody else it could be like
but why didn't you pick up the phone
that's so selfish of you to not take
what that other person was thinking into
consideration and you could talk to
another person and they'll have a
completely different perspective but
like for us in the room right now how do
you
communicate
what you need
for yourself to someone else and can we
expect other people to truly understand
what our version of self-love is
without it coming off selfish or is it
just something like
we're gonna it might work with one
person and not with another yeah
um i'm very i communicate what i want
need and like and dislike very well um i
used to not always be like that but then
over the years i've learned people are
not going to know unless you say
something you can't expect people to
read your mind
um so i really put it out there if
someone did me wrong and if it bothers
me like enough to like i don't want to
let it slide and we're going to be in
close proximity with each other for a
while um then i'm gonna bring it up but
i'm not gonna be a [ __ ] about it you
know
and i bring it up in like a healthy like
hey i really want to discuss this
you know and for the most part it does
work out
and then as your own like cell form of
self-love i was just talking about this
to another friend the other night um
my self-love is taking a nap
or like
one day where i just don't do anything
and he's like one of those like rise and
grind blah blah blah nfts whatever right
and he's like well no that's a waste i'm
like he just doesn't understand like
what you need and what i need so i
explained to him i believe that time
enjoyed is not time wasted where you
believe my nap is time wasted no i
enjoyed that it's good for me and i'm
going to do that even if you don't
see that you know so everyone's
self-love is different yeah exactly
someone's self-love might be i spend
time crocheting like the [ __ ] is that
that's boring as [ __ ] you know like you
can't expect everyone to know your own
form of self-love and you can't
um and you should try not to like [ __ ]
on other people's way of self-love and
it's not harming anyone or themselves
yeah that's a good point because i
totally relate to that too but going
back to what you're saying about like
communicating i for [ __ ] sure
struggled like crazy communicating
my needs or whenever i felt like there
was something that needed to be
communicated with someone when i felt
wronged or whatever
um but then when like i also found it
very difficult because
like it also depends on who you're
communicating with right because then
there'll be there'll be situations where
i am trying to express like hey i was
really hurt by
what you did but then like a person
would be
they'll they'll go into their avoidance
tendencies and be like oh well that's
just your fault on how you took it and
it's just like um okay i'm already
struggling like crazy trying to
communicate this and then it's like it
feels like a gaslighting situation so
then i don't know then after like
situation after situation especially
with like the same people over and over
again you end up just like being like
okay well let me just swallow this yeah
and this will be my but then i get avoid
it yeah and then that resentment grows
and then that was a lesson that i really
learned
um that
by no matter how difficult it is to
communicate
your emotions especially to people that
you care about like that's just a a
hurdle you have to get over in order to
better the relationship because i know i
wasn't
i wasn't doing the relationship any
favors by staying quiet a lot of the
times because i was uncomfortable with
the way that they would respond right
like you know it was just it's like that
was not helping the relationship at all
and it it it just it taught me a lesson
where it's like well i need to learn how
to communicate better also be
better at maneuvering whatever it is
that they're giving me and being like no
hold on let's focus yeah let's focus on
what we're talking about
um because then it'll end up being like
distractions or
uh yeah the gaslighting thing just get
really difficult but i think i ended up
learning that lesson pretty well because
i remember
um when was it gina like we ended up
having like a little thing with me and
you remember we were going to be
shooting at airbnb and then oh it's like
a little like
misunderstanding not misunderstood time
it was something yeah between us and
then i don't know how you received it
but i felt like that moment for me was
like a personal growth moment of like
communicating yeah this was the first
time that you actually got upset with me
about something it's because of my poor
timing issues
yeah but i guess like the way that i
presented it to you yeah
i don't know how you receive it i took
it as oh if
because you've like i know how you are
you
don't really voice anything that bothers
you yeah um
so the fact that you actually did voice
it i took it very seriously i'm like oh
[ __ ] like if tiffany's saying something
then i i really need to be receptive and
listen and which i really appreciated
because you did great receiving it but
that's what made me feel like oh my god
maybe i'm growing yeah she's receiving
this really well and you don't want and
so i took it as okay you're right tiff
and i'm so sorry i do need to um be
better at this and i understood like i
know that my time um
management is poor and
if it's so important in fact to the
point where
tiff is saying something that's how i
know it's a [ __ ] issue you know
because jess will call me out
immediately but you like if it's like
it's like
pissing off like the nicest sweetest
person right ever you know and you're
like oh [ __ ] i really did [ __ ] up and
that is personal growth because you
said something
and
it
the outcome of that was positive yeah
and that that was really reinforces you
saying like okay cool i should bring out
like i should speak up more when i need
to and then for me it was self-growth
for me because
for me it was always like oh you know
that's just how i am they know that's
the toxic thing yeah
you know like asian time but then i
realized okay i really can't do that
that's really [ __ ] up it's bothering
my friends you know um
and plus
adding to that
if you were to say that to me and i was
not receptive like now whatever and i
continue doing it those are not the type
of friends you want in your life anyways
um if bringing up something that bothers
you makes someone just like ugh whatever
blah blah blah like
that's a conflict that
even if it not did not turn out the way
you wanted to be it did not turn out
positive the silver lining is now you
understand that's not the type of person
i want in my life true yeah yeah yeah
conflict like ends up raising
your true colors yeah like how people
deal with conflict
uh so the conclusion of this article
says so what exactly is self-love then
self-love is about taking care of
yourself mentally physically and
emotionally it is not all pampering and
positivity it is a mindful act of
awareness of your thoughts feelings and
behavior as a way to improve yourself
self-love helps you set good values
boundaries with others and protect your
energy it is about self-compassion and
learning to have a better relationship
with yourself inside and out if we have
a lot of negative self-talk or negative
held beliefs about self it may feel
unattainable to strive for self-love it
is okay to strive for self-compassion or
self-forgiveness instead of self-love
when you embark in this process
forgiveness is the biggest takeaway from
that blessing
is one of the biggest takeaways a lot of
the times we
project who we want to be but on the
like on the inside we're not enough
we're constantly
comparing we're constantly just feeling
like we have to put on an act in a show
and we don't forgive ourselves for the
things that we didn't know a lot of our
experiences and being toxic like we
don't have the best examples at times um
everybody is growing constantly and
there is going to be a time where you
have to forgive the mistakes that you've
made and if you never do that that's
when you become extremely judgmental
yeah it's when you become so
it just
not you yeah and
the step to self-love is forgiveness it
is honestly taking a hard look in
and saying
i understand that person i was at that
time
i don't want to be that person again
i've experienced this if i don't grow
from it then i've learned nothing right
right and just trying to navigate
that it's a lot of
you
and it hurts growth sucks and it comes
with growing pains but also
if you're in a relationship with
somebody or you are around other people
whether it's work family friends husband
wife it doesn't matter you're always
going to have to
evaluate and re-evaluate constantly
because it's always evolving and
whatever happens today will determine
what happens tomorrow but we don't know
if tomorrow is going to be the same as
today so we have to learn to just keep
adjusting
and be forgiving
and self-love a lot of times doesn't
feel or look like self-love like you're
like there are times like why am i
sitting here letting myself cry why am i
sitting here you know like making myself
feel terrible but that sometimes is a
form of self-love because you're letting
yourself
be you and feel your real emotions it's
not a bad thing it's growth you know
you're helping yourself this is actually
sometimes self-love actually hurts
but it's something that you have to go
through
for a better you in the future you know
so let yourself do these things
sometimes yeah yeah it's healthy
so
hi everyone thanks for watching we hope
you learned something about self-love
today you know um take some time check
in with yourself but also check yourself
yeah
self-reflection be self-aware it's okay
baby it's hard we ain't perfect
it's all right and that is self-love
doesn't mean you hate yourself you gotta
tell yourself like well i'm [ __ ] up
whatever no it's self-love you're
learning yeah
with grace exactly yeah uh thank you
nicky for hanging out with us how does
that moment be oh i still got some work
to do oh we all do man after this after
this conversation i'm like yeah i got
some work i gotta do
i'm sitting here reflecting and hearing
everything you're saying nikki i'm like
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah i mean for
those of you at home who were like we
have a lot of young viewers who think
like oh they have their [ __ ] together
look at this she's got house family kids
whatever business whatever they know
what they're doing no we are still
learning man
learning never stops exactly and just
because you're not where you want to be
right now doesn't mean that you're not
going to get there eventually yes it is
all right nothing is ever set in stone
be willing to adjust plan and change and
it is all right nobody is perfect it is
okay and there is no there is no
timeline that you have to follow thank
you you don't have no self love by your
your thirties
no you can work on your own timeline
that's fine there's so many words never
stopped exactly never stops
so people listening right now y'all
ain't perfect either
nikki where can they check you out baby
what do you got going on you can check
me out on 997 now in san francisco with
big bay mornings my morning show monday
through friday um also you can check me
on the no chaser podcast with tim and
rick you can find me on instagram nikki
blades and also you can check out my
food stuff that i got going on with
nikki street eats also superb sportswear
i'm gonna have to get you guys fitted
with some shoes
get the whole crew laced up and if you
ever go to those sites you can use code
blades and uh you get a discount yay
and then make sure you guys check out
tiffin cases
they got some baby vlogs going on the
cutest thing in the world
yeah and then check me out on g4 tv yeah
twitch.g4tv or on my personal twitch
twitch.tv
slash miss gina darling watch me stream
watch me do dumb [ __ ] on tv
until next time wait don't forget our
sponsors oh yeah buy something
you [ __ ] coward spend money all the
links are down below
but don't
buy
you know buy all the things be toxic
with that one yeah
all right
[Music]
you